hessen kommen zu diesem video wir sind
in der gewohnten werkbank aber
nicht im gewohnten umfeld ich bin in der
neuen werkstatt wir sind natürlich
umgezogen mehr infos zum haus
tatsächlich gibt es ist absolut geil
aber heute soll es um diesen raum gehen
und zwar um diese werkstatt genauer
gesagt um diesen
hintergrund denn hier gerade sehen
werdet das ist nämlich kann aktuell noch
ziemlich kalt und weist und relativ
langweilig und das werden wir unter
anderem heute ändern und zwar werden wir
eine riesig fette werkzeug wand bauen
und zwar die aller geistlichen
vorstellen kann das soll wirklich
modular sein das heißt werkzeuge soll
mal einen tag tag einfach schön
organisieren können dann soll alles
mögliche dran dann soll schrauben
sortimente an sich auch im hammer und
eine säge und schraubenzieher und schön
sortiert und richtig übersichtlich und
natürlich aber auch vor allem schön ich
hatte mich viele werkzeuge die das
gesehen und oft sieht man abhängig
platten und so richtig ästhetisch
irgendwie ist das sehr sehr selten ich
habe ein bisschen inspiration aus dem
internet geholt und ich hab da so vor
dass ich quasi die wand da graut streich
oder sogar vielleicht ein bisschen beton
optik daran machen lassen das wäre mal
aussehen und dann die kacheln aus
schwarz gefährten heute mit den ganzen
berg daran meine inspiration seht hier
angewendet ist nur noch mit dem
franchise system dh ein system wo man
halt ganz zeitig irgendwie modul
werkzeug anhängen kann aber wozu mache
ich mir die mühe und erkläre ich dass
wenn ich es euch einfach per computer
visualisierung zeigen kann davor muss
sich allerdings auch den kompletten raum
ab müssen dieses video wird unterstützt
von der firma steckdosen würde ich
tatsächlich ein mit verkleiden weise
steckdosen findet zusätzlich generell
findet in weißem hintergrund super
langweilig genau haben wir uns noch
wasseranschlüsse weil theoretisch ist es
ja eine büro küche büro küche brauche
ich nicht kommt einfach weggehen aber
ich musste trotzdem ausmessen damit ich
nicht genau da rein so einen schönen
werkzeugschrank plane jetzt einfach time
labs wichtig so rumlaufen
[Musik]
jetzt wo ich die genauen daten mit
maßband ausgemessen habe mäßig mit dem
handy noch ein paar grobe daten aus
einfach per leider quasi raum ist 550
lang und in die richtung 650 und das
denkt sich auch ganz gut mit dem
grundriss und
jahrzehnte ganzen raum am pc nachgebaut
und zwar nicht nur so wie er aktuell ist
sondern bereits so wie ich ihn gerne
haben will die grauen kästen sind
schränke mit schubläden die dann durch
leimholz platten zur werkbank werden an
die wände kompletten für die modulare
werkzeug halterung uns darüber noch mehr
schränke den stauraum ist gold wert
übrigens gibt es hier in dem haus neben
der werkstatt auch einen extra lagerraum
eine garage mit geplantem holzlager
einen 3d druckraum ein büro und auch
einen großen garten aber eins nach dem
anderen für die werkbank ecke habe ich
mich wie bereits bei meiner alten
werkbank für massive eiche entschieden
allein die drei neuen platten ihre
kosten dabei inklusive
oberflächenbehandlungen und versand
stolze
1190 euro die vier schubladen schränke
hauen mit den insgesamt 2000 75 euro
sogar noch mehr rein beides zusammen
sorgt aber für eine wunderbare optik und
viel platz für die beiden neuen
mitarbeiter meine werkbank die ich aus
köln mitgenommen habe war die
inspiration dafür und steht nun in der
mitte des raumes auf rollen die platte
dafür hat damals 235 euro kostet und die
schubladen schränke jeweils 376 für
genau denselben habe ich übrigens jetzt
zwei jahre später einfach 485 geteilt
die idee von den dunklen platten auf der
hellen wand habe ich übrigens von diesem
pinterits bild das mich dann zu dieser
webseite von zwei richtig kassen
handwerkern geführt hat die wirklich
eine sehr ästhetische werkstatt haben
allerdings ist die art und weise wie die
werkzeuge hier angebracht sind zwar
hübsch aber für mich ich maximal
unpraktisch deshalb werde ich dafür ein
franchise system bauen mit vielen kai
leisten passend zu diesen schrägen kann
man dann später für werkzeuge und
zubehör halterungen anfertigen die man
dann wie hier zu sehen ist einfach wo
man will flexibel an die wand hängen
kann
[Musik]
richter school um die gewünschte
dunkelgraue holzoptik zu erhalten wird
das holz gebaut also eingefärbt im
gegensatz zum lackieren wird hier das
holz nicht in eine farbschicht gehüllt
sondern das holz auf die farbe einfach
auf wodurch die holzstruktur noch gut zu
sehen bleibt um genau den für mich
richtigen farbton zu erwischen haben wir
graue und schwarze gold gekauft und dann
verschiedene abstufungen gemischt und
uns für 50 50 entschieden da das sehr
gut zu den werkzeug schränken passt
jetzt wurde holzplatten ihre farbe haben
die wir übrigens bewusst etwas heller
gemacht haben als unsere inspiration
fehlt noch die farbe an der wand ich
finde weiße wände sehen immer super
schlimm aus auf der kamera deshalb
wollte ich eigentlich eine beton optik
sowie dave tchorz in seinem neuen büro
gemacht hat aber erstens ist das teuer
und zweitens hätte ich erst in drei
monaten einen termin bekommen also wird
das ganze einfach in ellgau gestrichen
ich habe übrigens während die maler da
waren den schlüssel zu dieser tür
verloren und musste sich daher mit einem
kleiderbügel knacken damit die maler
auch noch ins andere zimmer zu streichen
gelangen konnten wenn ihr sehen wollt
wie genau ich das angestellt habe ich
mal meinen neuen youtube-kanal aus den
ich euch verlinkt haben
jetzt wo die wände der wunderschönen
gestrichen sind kann ich auch endlich
diese werkzeug haltungs platten an die
wand aufhängen diese dinge auch schon
fertig gebaut also gefärbt und auch
schon gelöst jetzt allerdings verfehlt
ist es diese drüben bereits gefärbten
teile im genau gleichen abstand auf
diese platten anzubringen da mache ich
mir jetzt hier an der tischkreissäge mit
meinem ersten tischkreissäge schnitt so
einen abstandshalter für zwischen diese
dinge dann bin ich nicht immer alles
ausweist muss ich habe schon mal einer
großen format kreissäge geschnitten
allerdings ist sehr sehr lang her eine
tischkreissäge scheint jetzt im ersten
beitrag auch extrem viele videos und
anleitungen und sowas angeschaut dann
bin ich ja nichts falsch machen weil das
ist das mächtigste und gefährlichste
teil was entsprechend hier eine
schutzbrille und auch gehörschutz
absorberanlage die wir gebaut haben die
ist schon angesteckt das heißt wenn ich
jetzt die kreissäge einmal anmache geht
die auch mit an
[Musik]
die absage geht automatisch aus wenn das
ding aus ist und jetzt ist das teil
fertig es hat spaß gemacht bleibt jetzt
können wir die ganzen leisten im
perfekten abstand anbringen die garage
und jetzt kann es losgehen glaube ich
mal
so wird man gefahren eigen gemacht hier
sind mit ein paar klemmen zu arbeiten
und eigentlich sagen auch vor bohren so
dass ich jetzt ein zweiter akku
schrauber geholt sind erst vor kurzem
beim baumarkt geholt habt über schub mit
unserem heutigen sponsor habe ich auf
die online bestellung von ungefähr 142
euro einfach 5 eur an und sind nicht an
cash back zurück bekommen ohne irgendwas
dafür zu machen cashback bedeutet dass
ihr bei eurem online einkauf bares geld
zurückbekommt die anmeldung ist
kostenlos und es gibt über 2000 partner
wie zb mediamarkt booking.com ebay oder
lieferanten über den ihr so cashback
sondern könnten es sogar schon ab einem
euro cashback direkt aufs bankkonto oder
per paypal auszahlen lassen könnt eure
daten sind auch kommt es sicher weil
schub keinen datenhandel betreibt
sondern sich einfach einen kleinen teil
der vermittlungsprovision 1 behält und
sich damit finanziert der restliche teil
der provision wird an die user als
cashback ausgezahlt schubert bereits
über 1,7 millionen user in deutschland
und ist damit das führende cashback
portal das ganze super easy an der
überschuss auf eure lieblings klicken
wie gewohnt einkaufen
und anschließend erhaltet ihr einen teil
des einkaufs märz auf euren job account
gutgeschrieben sich jetzt auf den link
in der video beschreibung meldet euch
bei schub an und ihr bekommt zehn euro
extra cash back bei eurem ersten einkauf
und in diesem akku schrauber habe ich
jetzt hier so einen bohrstopp drin das
heißt ich kann genau 3 cm wunderbaren
dann akkuschrauber switchen
so jetzt ist der spread drin jetzt komme
hier rüber zu den siebzigern endlich mal
ob das hier genau angeht ja nicht
perfekt aber auch wenn man gut genug so
die spar nicht fest wenn ihr da fleißig
vorgebohrt und
fliegender wechsel deswegen ist es sogar
mit 1 2 abgestellt zu haben jetzt kommt
endlich ist es abstand stücken spielt
lege ich einfach mal dran dann kommt die
nächste leiste
und da geht man raus und zack an den
perfekten abstand ohne dass man
irgendwann messen musste und dort eine
menge zeit gestoppt
[Musik]
nachdem diese wunderschönen wenn ihr
jetzt fertig sind müssen die an die wand
gebracht werde und das ist überhaupt
nicht so leicht wie man denkt ich habe
das schon mal gerade eben grob geplant
wo welche schraube hingehören könnte und
wieder stabil sein könnte das muss ich
jetzt einmal grob einzeichnen dann will
ich hier checken kann ob ein stromkabel
teuer ist und die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
sogar relativ groß denn das war
eigentlich mal heißt küche gedacht und
deswegen haben wir hier überall
stromleitungen und da oben ist auch noch
strom nicht sogar deswegen checken wir
dass sicherheit geht vor
[Musik]
das ist genau da strophen hervor ich
ihnen wollen sollte ja gut macht
aussehen und direkt per steckdose hat
auch wenn die stromleitung in der wand
das platzieren der platten etwas
komplizierter gemacht hat als es hätte
sein müssen habe ich nach etwas messen
und überlegen an der position gefunden
die mir gefällt das aufhängen brauche
ich hilfe und hat mir dafür soviel
geschnappt die gerade dabei war uns bei
30 grad ein hochbeet in den garten zu
zimmern
[Musik]
jesus manchmal sind die hohlräume sind
die noch mehr angst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hab mir überlegt wie ich das auch
alleine auf 1990 drücken so ein bisschen
kompliziert aber eigentlich und
vorsichtig ist geht das auch nicht gut
perfekt auch die leistung
was man auf antalya war das anstrengend
aber ich bin mega happy
bevor ich jetzt aber die werkbänke
wieder an ihrem platz jubel muss ich
hier irgend eine art schutz materialien
lägen damit der holzboden nicht
beschädigt wird und mich unsere
tatsächlich ultra netten vermieter nicht
bald hassen da die meisten einfach zu
verlegen werkstatt böden aber super
langweilig und hässlich sind die sich
jetzt zum holz großhandel um so mehr
robustes fake holz aus plastik aus dass
ich einfach über den aktuellen holzboden
darüber legen kann und wenn wir
irgendwann mal wieder ausziehen kann man
ihn aber wieder wegmachen das ganze
kostet 1300 euro ist aber trotzdem viel
günstiger als das komplette parkett zu
ruinieren und am ende ersetzen zu müssen
also habe absolut keine aber so
funktioniert dies nur vorstellen macht
auf jeden fall nicht nach weil es ist
absolut unfassbar gefährlich aus let's
go
[Musik]
als ob das wirklich funktioniert hat
der dümmste welt
nicht so ja du hast es nicht anders
gewollt tür
[Musik]
darüber kann ich mich später ferrari
zweiter unschwer zu erkennen ist habe
ich eigentlich keine ahnung was ich hier
mache weil ich noch nie in den boden
verlegt habe der trick ist es dabei so
selbstbewusst rüberzukommen dass der
boden nicht merkt dass man eigentlich
gar keinen plan hat dann lässt das sich
nämlich trotzdem ganz cool verlegen den
boden hier rein zu zimmern hat echt ne
ganze weile gedauert doch hier sehe ich
endlich das letzte stück holz mit meiner
neuen tischkreissäge mit der ich mich
dann diesem projekt direkt vertraut
machen konnte und fast als letztes säge
ich noch die türschwelle zurecht und
schraubt sie mit extra gebohrten löchern
in meinen neu verlegten boden in das
gute daran zu bohren wer jetzt nicht so
richtig sinn der sache
so und so sieht die neue werkstatt jetzt
von einer kameraperspektive haus und ich
sag mal so ich kann mich daran gewöhnt
ich finde es schön das war genau die
richtige entscheidung die wände zu
färben bei reis hat aber nicht so
gemacht haben dieses leichten grau blaue
hinten finde ich unfair kontrast zu
diesen orangenen holzplatten und die
böden in die luft besser heißt die
reporterin sind auch wenn die gar nicht
sieht sogar schon die böden und wenn
hier ein bisschen kaputt geht ist egal
die einnahmen daraus aber moment was
haben wir denn hier eine mega der
absauganlage menge spaß den ich bisher
vorenthalten hat kann er nicht sein wie
ihr wisst entsteht beim handwerken vor
allem an der tischkreissäge super viel
staub und späne und damit dass nicht
überall rum liegt haben wir uns eine
mobile absauganlage überlegt und zwar
ist das nicht nur ein staubsauger mit
ordentlich wumms auf den schlechten
selbstgemachten skateboard sondern wir
haben noch einen sogenannten zyklon
davor gestaltet die späne werden also
angesaugt wird im zyklon bisschen
rummachen paar umdrehungen ein bisschen
nach unten fallen in diesem behälter und
können dann easy entleert werden ohne
dass das ganze holz direkt den teuren
staubsauger filter vollmacht gekostet
hat das ganze inklusive rollen schläuche
fast zyklon usw 303 euro und kann jetzt
einfach an all unsere geräte angesteckt
werden egal ob die handkreissäge die
große tischkreissäge oder der
bandschleifer und geparkt wird der
kollege hier in der ecke wo er nicht im
weg rum steht aber wir sind noch nicht
fertig wir brauchen nur eins und zwei
die menge stauraum und der kommt jetzt
hier oben hin
[Musik]
bei einem der sieben hängeschränke für
insgesamt bringen 763 euro hatte ich die
idee in den kopf kürzer zu sägen damit
noch ein halber mehr rein passt als hier
in meinem plan damit die abgesägten
enden der aufklappbaren tür nicht offen
sind und das billige sperrholz nicht ich
weiß hat man oder fuchs einfach das von
ihr vom alten ende gemopst und ob es
neue draufgeklebt somit ist die reihe
der hängeschränke jetzt exakt genauso
lang wie die reihe der holzplatten
darunter damit dass mit der kreissäge
nicht weiterhin song contest nicht
vorhin beim laminat bauen ihr oder eher
gesagt baut man eine extra
tischkreissäge tisch und zwar nach der
anleitung von lets bastelt er macht auch
am sex videos und hat im gegensatz zu
mir sogar was drauf wir also man
befolgen auch noch nicht als bauplan den
wir nicht eine szene aus seinem shop
gekauft haben allerdings wenn wir das
ding mal ein bisschen tune aber seht
selbst
der erste unterschied ist dass wir keine
spanplatten verwenden sondern die
fünfmal so teuer in multiplex platten
damit der tischkreissäge unterschrank zu
unseren werkzeug wänden passt und weil
ich die optik aber viel schöner finde
dass und auf die tatsache dass sich
werkzeug oft nach den kriterien kaufe
dass es nicht nur auf gut ist sondern
auch in unserer farbschema passt das
wird natürlich für den richtigen
handwerksbetrieb oder sogar
hobbyhandwerker niemals sinn machen aber
da wir ja mit videos unser geld
verdienen darf schöne optik ruhig was
kosten um genau zu sein sagenhafte
626 euro allein für die holzplatten und
auch mal 277 euro für rollen griffe der
fräs tisch einlagen platte und vor allem
schubladen auszüge diesen mega teuer
außerdem wollen wir dass die
auflagefläche der kreissäge genau eben
ist mit den anderen werkbänken damit man
lange dinge besser darüber rutschen kann
und das nicht so endet wie hier wo ich
einfach ein paar pakete darunter gelegt
habt also fliegt im vergleich zu mich
als original bauplan eine schuppler der
komplett raus und das ganze ding wird
kürzer in der höhe und zum schluss mit
der tischkreissäge unterschrank
natürlich noch gewalt dann stimmt die
optik aber auch wirklich zu 100 prozent
[Musik]
jetzt einmal der fertige tischkreissäge
tisch keine ahnung mit schubläden und so
weiter und so fort mega geil hier oben
ist dann quasi das staub der kommt an
bunten rein und dann kann man den
einfach wie sie austauschen und das
gleiche daran ist dass es einfacher ist
man kann es da jetzt nicht rausziehen
man kann einfach hier hinfahren man kann
natürlich einfach mal eine werkbank hier
auch auf dem weg schieben das ist mega
praktisch und hat dann quasi hier in der
mitte richtig viel platz und optisch
passt der kreis denkt ist auch genau zu
diesen wänden wurden schon die ersten
sachen kann hier zum beispiel ein paar
segen akkuschrauber da kommt noch viel
zeug dazu dient die werkzeug wenn dir
machen sich genau so wie es geplant hat
man kann einfach sachen hier nehmen dann
wieder reinhängen und wenn man dann
diesen akkuschrauber an macht gerne mit
ganz woanders hätte da kommt man also
hier rüber und hängt das einfach hier
oben dran und da hängt aber ganz
woanders und man kann das ich je nachdem
was kann abgeht sie haben also zu recht
schieben wie man will da oben da mal ein
bisschen lachen und so weiter und so
fort ein paar töne also viel platz auch
dieser haufen der schande und räder
immer noch ist muss er weg oder wir dann
schön fein säuberlich hier überall
einsortiert sämtliche fans krieg
halterungen also wie zum beispiel das
stift halte hier wurden übrigens in 3d
drucker gemacht im parlament das fast
gar nicht wie wenn dir selber aus eben
dieser akustischen die man auch einmal
raus nehmen kann wenn man einen schönen
akkus
die ist auch aus ist multiplex platten
also aus holz einmaleffekten habe ich
leider noch nicht so cool ist liebling
dann noch eines loch wand hier und die
will ich irgendwann auch noch mal
austauschen vielleicht durch seine
fitness die man hier ja so rausziehen
kann von der reise ganz mir natürlich
auch in den schubladen der staat die
übrigens mittlerweile beschriftet sind
richtig professionell zum beispiel
hierbei messinstrumente da hat man alle
möglich messinstrumente drinnen
schreiner linke zollstock eine feinwaage
radien irgendwie zum messgerät
thermometer hier seine fühler leder also
es wirklich alles möglich und da drüben
haben natürlich klassiker zahn
kombizange zeiten schneider und so
weiter und so fort was hat der spaß
gekostet alles also mädels gesehen habt
bisher waren 9000 619 euro
das schon mal recht gekonnt viel dazu
zum beispiel eine handkreissäge in
exzellenter schleife noch andere
akkuschrauber die schon davor hatte der
band schleife die stand bohrmaschine und
ganz viele sachen und auch eine kappsäge
für 500 euro die hier noch kommt die
aktion ok und damit kommen land auf
19.700 euro was richtig wählt ist sprich
für 3d drucker werkzeug und so weiter
und so fort verbrauchs gegenstände sind
aber nicht dabei also schrauben
kegelbahnen 23 wort habe ich nicht
mitgenommen sondern nur werkzeuge und
geräte und einrichtungen die mal für
immer hat das ist für mich mega viel
geld allerdings in einer richtigen
werkstatt kann sich auch sein dass eine
cnc-maschine viel mehr kostet als das
ganze hier wird 90 prozent von alledem
was hier ist es online bestellen worden
wenn ihr auch viel online bestellt dann
checkt unbedingt schub aus könnt ihr mit
cashback ganz leicht viel geld
zurückbekommen es gibt noch ein paar
pläne für die zukunft ich will aber
nicht voll dann vielleicht habt ihr
ideen und damit bin ich aus macht's gut